Bon les mecs, merci d'être là pour écrire la prochaine saison de "Walking Dead".
Alors comme dans toutes les saisons, je vous rappelle un petit peu les règles :
Cinquante litre de sang perdu par épisode.
Munitions de pistolet illimitées.
Et bien sûr, on n'utilise jamais le mot : "Zombie".
Des rôdeurs.
Ouais, tu veux dire des zombies.
Des errants.
On dit zombie.
Des infectés.
Bon, mec, on dit zombie.
Même entre nous on dit zombie !
C'est bien une phrase de rôdeur ça !
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour le premier épisode de la nouvelle saison?
Bah écoute, je sais pas on fait comme d'habitude, hein? On se prend pas la tête.
J'ai une super idée.
J'ai l'impression que les Dragons nous ont suivis dans tout Westeros.
Timothé, on est pas dans Games of Thrones là ! On est dans Walking Dead !
J'ai ! Eventuellement Henri pourrait faire une grosse révélation
Genre, une maladie grave
J'ai une carence en potassium
Il me reste toute ma vie à vivre sans problèmes
Timothé, t'es viré
Carrément, je suis d'accord
Du coup j'attend la pause dej ou je pars maintenant ?
Ah non t'es viré direct, là maintenant ouais
D'accord, ok
Alors on change pas les trucs qui marchent dans la série par exemple
le fait que le bruit attire les zombies je trouve ça plutôt cool
Bien sûr
Ah ouais d'ailleurs, moi j'avais pensé à un truc
"bruit de moteur de voiture"
Arrête ce bruit ça va attirer les rôdeurs !
J'arrive pas à l'arrêter
Jul ! "musique de Jul"
Bah moi j'aime bien
t'aimes bien Jul ?
Ouais, l'album est assez efficace je trouve
le track 2 ouais
Alors, quand un zombie mord un humain,
On garde le concept, l'humain n'est pas tout de suite transformé en zombie
ça met un petit peu de temps hein
Oui, bien sûr, là d'ailleurs j'avais pensé que ce serait peut être l'occasion de faire une scène
qui montre que l'amitié
est toujours plus forte que l'épidémie
En tout cas toi et moi on est vraiment des frères hein
depuis le début on est inséparable, et je pense que ce sera comme ça
pour toute la vie
ouais
quoi que, tu sais quoi, marche un peu devant, prend un peu de recul
faisons un life
Non mais attend, non mais Rick, tu peux pas dire ça
on est comme deux frères, on est lié, on est
insépar..aaaa, et en même temps, on peut aussi être deux frères
et vire, euh et vivre un peu loin de l'autre quoi
Pourquoi tu sors ton flingue comme ça
Je sais pas non, on sécu, comme un pote quoi
Je me permets mais, est-ce qu'on tafferais pas un peu
sur la vitesse des zombies ?
Pourquoi ?
"bruits de zombies"
Ils sont pas rapides rapides là hein
je pense on a le temps hein
Ouais
"bruits de zombies"
Je verrais bien une petite cheminée là
Ah c'est vrai que ce serait pas mal oui
bruits de zombies
Tiens fiston, ton goûter
Merci papa
j'ai peut-être une idée pour régler ça
mais je sens que vous allez vraiment pas aimer
ouais, ça me déplais déjà
Vous aimez pas hein ?
Nan, bon les mecs
il nous faut un truc nouveau là il faut de la fraîcheur
des nouveaux zombies on pourrait pas avoir
des zombies un peu modernes
Ahahah! Le loser
Moi ça j'ai arrêté
Aujourd'hui je mange que des humains issus de l'agriculture biologique
élevés en plein air pas
pas stressés, tués avec respect tu vois
Ouais je vois mais tu
manges encore de la viande toi t'es
t'es pas végé, ah ouais si si carrément
Ouais j'oubliais c'était mon dernier
Ouais les mec je sais pas faut se diversifier là
faut un nouveau truc, un nouveau perso
Okay, bah dans se cas on fait comme d'hab et comme
dans toutes les séries, on fait arriver un nouveau personnage
hyper attachant pour que les gens l'aiment à fond
ouais j'aime bien ça continue ouais
Il est adorable, il est altruiste
Il a construit un peu pour relier un village à une école tu vois pour les enfants
Il adore les chiots, il en a quatre
Il y en a un qui a une patte cassée mais il s'en occupe
tu vois super bien et PAF! on le tue
Oh J'adore (SUPERBE)
Tu m'en fait huit comme ça hyper adorable
et on les tue. Alors moi j'avais un personnage
euh raciste, violeur
cannibale, vraiment le mec horrible quoi
Excellent, lui on le garde en vie très très longtemps
pendant trois saisons. Oh putain on a la pression là
Les français vont être au taquet pour regarder chaque
nouvel épisode. Ouais enfin au taquet
nous on a toujours les épisodes un peu après, bah non avec OCS
regardez quasiment en simultané la prochaine saison donc
Ah d'accord donc tu fais du placement de produit
Tu me dégoûtes, je quitte la réunion !
Je quitte la réunion aussi !  bah nan je
Oh putain moi aussi je me dégoûte, vas-y je quitte la réunion
Bon, un nouveau genre c'est cool
mais il lui faut une nouvelle arme fétiche
hyper violente
Ah ouais genre des pouvoirs
magiques... NAN !
Dans Game of Thrones ils ont des pouvoirs magiques
mais là on est dans Walking Dead donc il y a pas de pouvoirs magiques
Voilà pourquoi tu es reviré, ouais
et c'est mérité, je vous laisse
Euh...Ah...Sinon
on pourrait prendre une batte de Baseball
qu'on entoure de barbelés et genre
on lui donne un prénom à la batte tu vois, genre un prénom badass
Fais tes prières
Tu vas recevoir un coup de la part de Gisèle
Ah ! C'est un peu vieillot ça
quand même. Tu vas recevoir un coup
de la part de Titouan. C'est pas très méchant ça.
Tu vas prendre un coup de Jean-Luc
Ça sonne trop Jean-Luc
Tu vas prendre un coup de Daenerys
Ah mais je vais te virer ! Prépare-toi à recevoir un coup...
...de Jacques Chirac, tu ne peux pas mettre un nom
complet bordel ! et en plus
de président ! Euh, excusez-moi je me repermets
mais je me demande quand même c'est possible
qu'en sept saisons avec tous les zombies
qui croisent, il est jamais vu
euh... un zombie du genre
''Si on se dépêche on devrait arriver, Oh mec c'est Rihanna
Oh génial !
SELFIE
Peut me chanter Work Work Work
Ouais nan laisse tomber en fait
Eh regardez il y a Michel Drucker en zombie
Mais nan où ça ? Ah nan c'est juste Michel
Drucker en fait en pas zombie.
Alors c'est pas mal mais il nous faut une fin hein.
Alors justement j'avais une idée
"Bruits de zombies
NAN !!
Ahahah ! C'est une caméra cachée
on t'as piégé pendant huit ans
Ahahah ! Une caméra ici, une autre
là-bas, tu t'es fait avoir, c'est excellent !
Ça veut dire que ma femme elle est pas morte ?
Alors là on a un peu hésité du coup
pour la véracité du truc on est allé jusqu'au bout elle est morte hein.
Par contre, pour te consoler  t'as gagné
un superbe aspirateur d'une valeur de 35 euros.
Applaudissements
NON,NON,NON !! archi nul
Il faut rester dans l'univers Walking Dead
Autre chose, Ok j'ai
Bon c'est une fin un peu classique mais la fameuse
technique du personnage mystère
Vous êtes qui ?
Je suis...
Vous êtes qui en vrai ?
C'est quoi votre nom ? En fait il vaut mieux que
je reste de dos parce qu'à chaque fois que je me retourne, il y a le générique
qui se lance grossomerdo, les gens oublieront qui je suis
au prochain épisode. Essayez juste pour voir !
Je veux bien essayer.
Ah ouais c'est relou ouais
Je veux du spectacle ! Je veux créer
une vrai galère pour faire un énorme cliffhanger.
Faut foutre les personnages le plus possible dans la merde
Le plus possible ?
Ok !
Je veux pas mourir maintenant, t'inquiètes pas je te tiens
Ah tiens Eric, je vais te donner
un coup de ma batte qui s'appelle Lionel
Déconne pas ! Attendez !
Je vous ai pas tout dit
J'ai une carence en potassium ! Dommage...
... j'avais justement une banane, un fruit
très riche en potassium
NAN ! Salaud ! Ah !
Au revoir la banane !
Mais vous êtes qui ? Je suis...
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, je me suis marré à l'écrire
et à la jouer avec mes potes Julien, Raph
et Kaza. Si vous avez aimé ce concept un petit peu nouveau
un petit peu spécial, n'hésitez pas à me dire dans les commentaires
quelles sont vos séries préférées, peut-être qu'on pourra
faire une nouvelle vidéo sur une autre série
J'en sais rien, on verra bien, et si ce n'est pas déjà fait
Abonnez-vous à ma chaîne Youtube et on se revoit très très
bientôt pour l'amour du love Ciao !
Oh nan, elle me mord
Ça y est je suis mordu
Eh je suis un zombie.